and we're now just waiting for Lock's
loading conclusion on the second stage
again that should be at the T minus two
minute mark
again coming up next at T minus two
minutes will be liquid oxygen loading
complete on the second stage
foreign
and there's that call out Falcon 9 is
now fully loaded with one million pounds
of fuel and liquid oxygen now the
booster that you see on your screen is
applying for the eighth time today
having previously supported scs-22.
ice spaces hakudo R mission one his
Passat amazonas Nexus
crs-27 and three starlink missions
after liftoff and Stage separation the
booster is scheduled to land on our
drone ship a shortfall of Gravitas and
you can see an amazing view of that on
your screen right there
successfully recovering parts of the
rocket allows SpaceX to re-fly the most
expensive parts of the rocket which in
turn drives down the cost of space
access
Falcon 9 is in startup
and good call out there this means that
the internal flight computers have now
taken over the launch countdown and now
just waiting for the final call from the
launch director
LD go for launch
and great news the launch director has
given the final go to proceed for launch
so let's sit back and watch as Falcon 9
takes our 21 V2 mini starlink satellites
into space
hahaha
he went 15 seconds again
two minus ten nine eight seven six five
four three two one zero lift up
Vehicles teaching downrange
stage one propulsion is nominal
t plus 30 seconds into flight and Falcon
9 has successfully lifted off from space
launch complex 40 at 8 50 a.m Eastern
Time
power and Telemetry nominal
and we are throttling down the engines
in preparation for Max Q
what do you call SuperSonic
and just heard that call out that Falcon
9 is supersonic
that means that the vehicle is traveling
faster than the speed of sound
we are coming up on Max Q here in a few
seconds
[Applause]
and there's that call that we've just
passed through masks Max Q
now next up are a few events happening
back to back that will be Mikko stage
separation ses1 and fairing separation
Mikko is main engine cutoff that's where
we'll shut down all of those engines
engine chill has started
that's where we will shut down all those
engines that you see lit up on the
vehicle right now and that'll prepare
the vehicle for stage separation
first stage will begin to make its way
back down to Earth again we are
scheduled to land on a shortfall of
Gravitas today
and stage two will continue with ses1 or
second stage engine start one and that's
where we will ignite the mvac engine on
the second stage
shortly after mvac ignition we will also
separate the Fairing and the two fairing
halves will fall back down to earth
those few events coming up here in a few
seconds Mikko stage separation scs-1 and
fairing separation
main engine cutoff
stage separation confirmed
mvac ignition
and there we've had mikko's stage
separation and the ignition of the mvac
engine
you can see the first stage on your left
hand screen the grid fins are now
deploying with an awesome view of the
Earth in the background
the mvac engine ignited on the second
stage
faring separation confirmed
and a really cool view of the fairing
being separated from the second stage we
will attempt to recover the fairing
halves with our recovery vessel dug
today
some really awesome views with Earth in
the background again you are looking at
your left hand side is the first stage
your right hand side is the second stage
looking at our mbac engine
stage one is currently making its way
back down to earth
again we are scheduled to land on our
drone ship a shortfall of Gravitas a day
acquisition of signal Bermuda
and the V2 mini starlink payload is
still attached to the settings
and good call outs there
as I mentioned earlier today's starlink
Mission Mark spacex's 25th Mission this
year and second launch of our V2 mini
starlink satellites
stage one making its way back down to
earth using the four grid fins you can
see two on your screen on your left hand
screen
but there are four on the vehicle these
help guide the vehicle back to The
Landing Zone
you also can see some white pups there
that is the nitrogen gas
used for attitude control
and also getting a view looking forward
on the vehicle there
as a reminder starlink is a satellite
internet consolation designed
manufactured and operated by SpaceX to
provide high-speed low lace C internet
to people living in remote and Rural
locations around the globe
now coming up here shortly will be the
entry burn for the first stage vehicle
this will be three of nine engines
reigniting
stage one FTS has saved
stage one entry burn startup
and there you can see on your left hand
screen
the engines have reignited this is just
under a 20 second burn
and helps us load the vehicle down as
it's entering back into the Earth's
atmosphere
stage one extra burn shutdown stage two
FTS has saved
and you can see that the entry burn has
shut down
now the first day is used to launch our
21 V2 mini starlink satellites into
space a day is flying for the eighth
time
and it previously supported ses-22
ispaces hakudo R mission 1 hispasat
amazonus Nexus
crs-27 and three starlink missions
now we're just under a minute away from
The Landing burn on the first stage
this will be a single engine the center
E9 engine reigniting on the vehicle
the m1d engines have about 190 000
pounds of thrust so this is just enough
enough thrust to slow the vehicle down
right before touchdown
stage one transonic
and you heard that call out stage one is
transonic this means that the vehicle is
traveling near the speed of sound
now we will have second engine cut off
starter terminal guidance very shortly
after stage one
and there's that Landing burn startup
so let's watch this Falcon 9 touches
down on our drone ship a shortfall of
Gravitas
Landing light deploy
stage one light and confirmed
and some cheers there
the stage one vehicle has touched down
on a shortfall of Gravitas we've got
some really awesome daytime views of
that Landing
nominal orbit insertion
and great call out there we had second
engine cut off one as well as a call out
for good nominal insertion
now this Landing for Falcon 9 marks our
186 overall Landing of an orbital clasp
rocket including Falcon 9 and Falcon
heavy missions
and with confirmation of successful
first stage landing and second engine
cutoff that wraps up our coverage for
now
be sure to check our social media for
confirmation of starlink satellite